Without the Black Panther
that can't be good
When you left without saying a word it hurt
I regret not being there with all of you
it was not easy he was King and
black panther to everyone. But to me
he was everything. We are transformed in a
way through this experience all of us very
much believe that this feels like the most
important movie we've ever made that is what
every crew member focused on every day and none
more so than Ryan coogler at the helm of it all
Ryan is such a big heart
and such a great storyteller
the actors that he's brought together were filled
with emotion and passion reuniting with Ryan
cooler it was incredible his heart is really
pure and we should protect them at all costs
Ryan is an artist he has
the heart to listen to you
to look in your eyes and go deep not just in the
story but in your soul when you get down to what
makes this movie human that is where Ryan really
excels I think even in a world as Fantastical and
as magical and as exciting as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he just has an understanding of people
there's an embracing of culture and Ryan is going
a step further and we're remembering
we're restoring we're celebrating
above all it is a relationship movie
we'll have some incredible set pieces
but at the end of the day I think what people
are going to really remember is the conversations
how do you move forward after losing
someone that meant so much to you
you have to continue the legacy
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Black Panther video Marvel just dropped a
bunch of new footage so we'll break it down we
also found out what Marvel's plans for the New
Black Panther shuri in wakanda are going forward
in Marvel phase five after the events of the Black
Panther wakanda forever movie and it has a lot
to do with some very familiar plots that they
set up during black panther wakanda forever so
I'll explain everything if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll be posting my black panther review
tomorrow so look out for that we're also doing
a movie ticket giveaway for IMAX tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
post all your favorite moments from the trailers
so far starting with all the Thunderbolts the
Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross all the valve stuff
that they're setting up in Marvel phase five
because we know that the Thunderbolts movie
is coming right after Captain America 4 New World
Order and the Thunderbolts movie will be the last
Marvel Phase 5 movie in the same way that black
panther wakanda forever is the last Marvel phase
4 movie The Other big change after Avengers end
game is that they're not ending each phase with
an event Avengers movie they're ending a saga with
both Avengers movies Avengers 5 King Dynasty and
Avengers 6 Secret Wars and what they're doing
instead is just having really big movies like
really big ones as the end cappers for each of the
phases which means that the events of thunderbolts
is actually going to be a really big deal and for
the most part black panther wakanda forever is all
about wakanda versus Namor and the MCU version of
atlanteans which they're calling talocan but it's
basically that conflict from the comics like
two different nations going to war with each
other before t'challa's death it was going to be
two kings going to war with each other but now
obviously shuri is taking over as Black Panther
in a lot of the movie is them scrambling trying
to figure out how to move forward after t'challa's
death like what do we do now also dealing with the
events of the snap Ryan coogler actually said
that before Chadwick Boseman passed away he had
finished the script for the original version of
black panther wakana forever the plot was going
to be completely different because obviously
he was going to be the main character but like
right after he finished the script is when
he passed away so he didn't have a chance to
actually read the script in was he did pass away
obviously they had to decide what to do next and
then they completely reworked the movie around
that a lot of the movie is them dealing with the
grief of losing t'challa and trying to figure out
how to go next as a nation while they're having
all these problems with Namor over the idea of
vibranium the whole idea is that the rest of the
world now has learned about wakanda's resources
all the vibranium technology that they have and
they want it so a lot of what's happening in the
movie is the direct result of what black panther
did or t'challa did at the end of the first Black
Panther movie sort of revealing themselves opening
their borders so to speak kind of at the end of
the first movie to the United Nations and because
wakanda is so well defended like people can't just
walk into wakanda and take their vibranium the
rest of the world has started scouring the planet
for other sources of vibranium now that they know
that there's potentially more out there that's
eventually what leads them to finding Namor's
people in talocan underneath the waves looking for
underwater vibranium thus the conflict with Namor
because it sounds like namor blames a lot of what
happened on what wakanda did like you you revealed
all this to the world and now they're coming for
us as well we're threatened because of this and
now we found out what Val and Thunderbolt Ross are
doing in the MCU while these events are playing
out because obviously they have their own plans
too everyone playing the Agatha all along music
it was Thunderbolt Ross all along if you didn't
see the news they've officially recast the role
of Thunderbolt Ross and it's going to be Harrison
Ford in the MCU he's going to beat Thunderbolt
Ross inside Captain America 4 New World Order
and probably also during the Thunderbolts movie
but like he's Thunderbolt Ross going forward now
it's not a big Multiverse twist or anything like
that it's just like the first Iron Man movie in
the second Iron Man movie with them recasting
Roadie there's obviously a lot of reasons why
they recast him because they really want to use
Thunderbolt Ross and a lot of these plots going
forward and now we've learned that it has a lot
to do with vibranium in wakanda so we're talking
after the events of black panther wakanda forever
going forward in Marvel phase five like this this
whole new paradigm they call Captain America 4 new
world order it sounds like a lot of that plot is
meant to address what's happening with the Black
Panther plot invite premium going forward in the
MCU heading into Marvel Phase 6 and Secret Wars
everybody wants that sweet sweet vibranium
and there's only a couple places to get it
on planet Earth so if you remember the way that
Captain America Civil War used the Black Panther
character it was all about the death of his father
t'chalka and him seeking Revenge until he learned
that something larger was at play it was Baron's
emo manipulating him this whole time this time
it seems like their plans for including the Black
Panther character now the shuri version of black
panther New Black Panther in Captain America 4 in
wakanda in a larger way is through this vibranium
Thunderbolt Ross and Val plot I don't know how
much of the plot that that's going to cover
because obviously there's going to be a couple
other things going on during the movie there's
still lots of questions about how they're going
to pay off the world war Hulk and the scar Planet
Hulk teaser at the end of the She-Hulk series that
might wind up being something much bigger later on
like they might push that off to even further in
the future Marvel still has some legal issues in
releasing a new Hulk Solo movie I think they're
still working that out but it sounds like the
reason why Val was in all those post-credit scenes
slowly assembling a Thunderbolts team is because
they want to use them to get vibranium from
wakanda by force if necessary and that was the
real reason why she was telling us agent we're
going to have some work for you that we can't
necessarily call Captain America for like things
that he won't be able to do because obviously the
Falcon version of Captain America isn't going
to go against wakanda and black panther and try
to get vibranium from them by force so it almost
sounds like they're giving some of that Doom War
Doctor Doom plot in the comics to Thunderbolt
Ross and Val and that'll just play out during
Captain America 4 and then the Thunderbolts movie
it sounds like it's just part of Marvel's larger
plans to make wakanda a much more important place
in the future movies like what do people want with
wakanda in the future like obviously they have
really cool technology in their really cool place
to hide out in the big planetary Invasion like
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end game but
I think it's them just logically taking things
to the next step like okay black panther goes
to the United Nations reveals wakanda their
resources their technology to the rest of the
world obviously the other nations and the other
villains in the MCU are going to want a piece of
that and now we're just starting to see that
play out and it's just starting during black
panther wakanda forever like there's hints of
it and it says that this big conflict between
Namor and wakanda but really the elephant in
the room is people like Thunderbolt Ross people
like Dr Doom who want vibranium for themselves
and one of the bigger problems with characters
like Thunderbolt Ross obviously going to be their
Red Hulk eventually too gotta worry about that is
that even though he's doing all these Shady things
they're all sanctioned by the US military the U.S
government because for a while he was Secretary of
Defense inside the presidency and then he was also
director of the world Security Council which is
the worldwide organization that developed after
Thanos attack during the first Avengers movie
with the shitari so it's basically Thunderbolt
Ross doing what Iron Man was talking about doing
during Avengers Age of Ultron covering the world
in a suit of armor but doing it his way he wants
to cover the world in a suit of vibranium fun fact
too Riri Williams ironheart Mark II suit that you
see in all the trailers is a vibranium suit but
it just sounds like that's why Thunderbolt Ross
is such an important character to Marvel going
forward like yes they want to do all the Red
Hulk stuff and that's going to be really cool
but really they're setting him up as a much bigger
antagonist heading into Captain America 4 and then
the Thunderbolts movie my early Theory right now
is that obviously he won't totally be successful
and that's why they'll use the Thunderbolts during
the Thunderbolts movie like okay I can't do this
on the official channels we're going to use Black
Ops methods Val call your Thunderbolts characters
that you assembled and we'll send them to get
vibranium for us but post all your theories in
the comments below if Thunderbolt Ross and Val are
trying to use their resources to get vibranium how
do you think they're going to do it and which
movies do you think that's going to play out in
during Marvel phase five my black panther wakanda
forever review will post tomorrow so look out for
that my full post credit scene video Easter eggs
breakdown for the entire movie will post at the
end of this week after it actually comes out so
be sure to go see it as soon as possible and I'll
name a giveaway winner in my review video tomorrow
everyone click here for my new Spider-Man across
the spider-verse video and click here for that
new Thunderbolts teaser that they released at
d23 thank you so much for watching and everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!